all right so that's part a part b
that's the setup now let's have a look
at part c because this is
the real question that part a and b are
just kind of laying the foundation for
it says hence prove by contradiction
that any composite number
of the form for n minus one so now we
look at the other kinds
of odd numbers they must have at least
one prime factor
of the form four n minus one
what's going on here so what they're
saying is what we want to prove
is if you have a look at this four n
minus one
uh sequence of numbers right i need to
go a little bit further actually because
all of the four and minus ones that i've
got are three seven eleven
they're all prime and what they're
interested in here is the composite
numbers
that are in this four and minus one
format so let's just go a little bit
further um you can see i can go
upstairs i'm adding four each time so
the next one is 15 and then
19 and then 23. you know it just so
happens that in this whole list
the only one that i'm interested in here
is going to be 15. that's the only
composite number that i've written down
in this sequence so if i just have a
look at that 15
right there does it have at least one
prime factor
of the form 4-1 well you can quickly
verify that that is true
15 has two prime factors namely three
and five is one of those of that foreign
minus one
format and the answer is yes it is the
three
is in the four n minus one format and
you could keep going you know you can
see
27 uh that's three times nine so three
is i've already picked that one out um
and i could keep on going you know
any any time i go along in this sequence
this part c this result i'm trying to
prove is that at least one of the
factors will be the four n minus one
format
but they've also said prove this by
contradiction so i need to try and go
about this in an indirect way
this statement here um a composite
number of the form four n minus one
must have at least one prime factor of
the form four n minus one
take a breath if i want to prove this by
contradiction what i have to prove
is that the negation of this implication
the negation of this statement
is false i want to show that if if i try
and work with this negation
i just end up in a as the name suggests
contradiction i want to end up with
something
self-contradictory something
inconsistent so to do that
what i need to do is i need to state
this
implication in a clear form because i
need it in a clear form so i can negate
it
and then i'm going to assume that
negation is true and see where it leaves
me
okay so let's have a go at this how can
i state this
implication well i like to have things
in the form
you know p implies q
that's every every implication is of
this form
and the reason why i like this is
because if this is what the implication
looks like
if this is the implication then the
negation
can be written as rather than p
implies q i can say it's p implies
not q right so the order stays the same
the first part the um the anti-seq sedan
stays the same
but the implication is the part that
goes opposite um sorry not the
implication the uh
the consequent the part the second part
of this implication
so let's have a go let's try our hand at
writing it in the
p implies q or if p then q
kind of form so you can see if you have
a look carefully
there are two halves to this implication
right if you follow along with me
there's this part here any composite
number of the form
4n minus 1 and it says must so i could
say that in this way
if you have some sort of composite
number of this form
then and then here comes the second part
the consequent not the antecedent
then you can know uh that at least one
of the prime fact one of the prime
factors will be of the form
four n minus one if this first part here
then this second part here so let's have
a go at writing that
so the original implication is like slow
original implication
if k is a composite number i've already
been told that right from the outset
and i'm going to introduce uh you know
i'm going to say right at the very end
that um
k you know it's got these particular
qualities that i i
need to meet if k is a composite number
a composite number
[Applause]
and it's not just any composite number
it's one of the form
4n minus 1. so i'm going to write of the
form
for n minus 1. here's the if
what's the then what does it lead to
well it leads to the fact that at least
one of the prime factors
is of this form four n minus one so how
would i
write that i can say then
at least one right at least one of the
prime factors is of this form so let's
just write that then
at least one
and i'm just highlighting that
quantifier for me because it's going to
be very important when i negate this
statement
then at least one factor
is of that same form 4 minus 1.
four and minus one okay
now if that's what the implication looks
like you can see the uh
you know where's the p it's here
there's p and where's the q the q
it's here at least one factor is of the
form four n minus one i should put a
full stop there
um i want p to stay put so to write the
negation
uh let's write like so oh no i'll put in
red just to highlight that this is
different
here's the negation
for starters when you have a look the
negation of this implication
starts the same way p implies something
so i'm just going to take this whole
piece here
this is the if p component of it so i'm
just gonna
grab that there we go and now i need to
say
then what is the opposite of this orange
statement the opposite of having at
least one factor
is that i don't have any factors at all
that are of this form right that's the
only way that this doesn't happen like
at least one factor leaves room for the
fact that there could be two or three or
four or five
the only way that is the complete
opposite of at least one
is that there are none if you want to
think about this back in the language of
probability this is the complementary
event either at least one factor
is in this form or none of the factors
are in this form so therefore
that's the way i'm going to say
mitigation i'm going to say then
it has no um i think i'm missing the
word prime
as well because if i go back to the
question yep that's important says prime
there
so let's just add that in or how am i
going to do this
let's shift that over so i'm not missing
keywords
prime at least that part's important
okay here we go
back to the negation instead of at least
one prime factor i'm going to say it has
no prime factors
of the form 4n
minus 1. okay so there is the negation
this is what i'm trying to try and work
with and because this is a proof
by contradiction um what i'm hoping is
that once i sort of fiddle with this
negation um it's going to lead me to
something
that's contradictory and then i can say
medication's false original implication
is true that's the roadmap